in the seaside county of Ventura
California a storm is forming on the
horizon you won't see it on any weather
maps or meteorological charts you'll
find it brewing in the pages of the
county budget were hundreds of millions
of dollars in pension debt threatened to
drown the area the pension system right
now has a billion dollars unfunded
liability that's just simply
unsustainable we've seen the damage
these financial downpours can bring
higher taxes reduced public services and
in some cases bankruptcy so when the
winds began to change Ventura residents
left into action to enact reform in
November's midterm elections only to be
stopped by a judge before they could get
to the ballot box the faculty matters
they have huge liabilities hundreds of
millions of dollars and if they don't
address these liabilities now future
services will be cut why did reform fail
and why is it so hard to accomplish in
the first place what's stopping
governments from saving themselves from
a predictable flood of debt the county
has big guns but we're finding that the
Union together with the people have
bigger guns
the story of Venters failed pension
reform begins in 1947 when residents
elected to create the Ventura County
Employees Retirement Association also
known as vecera as the country emerged
from the Great Depression state saw
benefit in establishing retirement
systems that could act as a safety net
for workers to avoid poverty later in
life in California a 1937 lobby of
counties a choice they could become part
of the statewide retirement system or
they could create their own program 20
counties including Los Angeles San Diego
and Ventura chose the latter became
known as 37 act counties this
designation is important because if
Ventura voters could elect change it
could serve as a blueprint for the
remaining 37 act counties to enact
pension reform without having to go
through the legislative quagmire in
Sacramento since the 1940s the sara has
grown to cover some 16,000 County
government employees the fund is a
defined benefit program meaning that the
employer or in this case the county
promises their workers a fixed sum of
money when they retire for the rest of
their lives since defined benefit
systems provide retirement benefits that
are predetermined the county needs to
make sure they set aside enough money
each year to pay for future retirees
they do this by placing contributions
into a collective pension fund where
money is that invested to generate
revenue to cover future benefits of
investments consistently hit or exceed
their mark the county has no extra cost
but if they fall short of expected
returns as many do the taxpayer is
responsible not only for the cost of the
workers pension but for the cost of
additional debt payments as well the
government worker contributes just a
small fraction of their paycheck toward
the retirement fund for general county
workers that number is around seven
percent while public safety employees
contribute about fifteen percent the
taxpayers match those contributions and
pick up the payments for any debt that
has accrued after 35 years of service
the average county employee in Ventura
with an 85 thousand dollar salary can
expect to retire with a little over
74,000
and annual benefits on top of their
social security and 401k pay the average
public safety employee making a hundred
and twenty five thousand dollars a year
can expect to walk away with an annual
pension of a hundred thousand dollars
after 30 years of service you know when
you look at compensation and pension
particularly of the safety and the top
executives in county we're right up
there if not higher than anybody else
though the stewards of the pension fund
have invested responsibly they began to
notice a disturbing trend Bill Wilson
who has served on the Retirement Board
for over 16 years explains we've been
earning very good returns ever since
1994 despite that here we are with a
billion dollars in unfunded liability
you can't tell me that's right the
recent economic recession hasn't helped
veceras bottom line but it doesn't fully
explain why the system is so far in the
red in 1999 pension payments accounted
for just one percent of the total budget
today that number is seventeen percent
as retirement eat up a bigger portion of
the budget the amount residents have had
to kick in to cover pension obligations
has also increased today taxpayers pay a
hundred and fifty three million dollars
per year to the pension system that's
triple the number they paid out over a
decade ago in the next five years that
number is expected to climb to 226
million some of the rising costs can be
attributed to demographics retirees are
living longer and drawing more in
pension payments unrealistic investment
targets have also hampered growth in the
retirement system while Ventura assumes
the standard seven point seven five
percent return on retirement investments
the county has seen just a 5.8 two
percent return in the last five years in
addition to these factors the county
also has the distinction of having some
of the highest retirement benefits in
the state thanks to a practice known as
spiking in which retirees can manipulate
their final pay with supplemental
benefits to boost their pensions a 1997
state Supreme Court ruling known as
livin
her decision upheld this practice which
legitimized pension spiking throughout
the state after the ruling stories of
outrageous pensions began to make their
way into the headlines in 2012 it was
discovered that County Executive Marty
Robinson had added thousands of dollars
of unused sick pay and bonuses to spike
her final pension pay over forty
thousand dollars more a year more
recently former County Sheriff Bob
Brooks made headlines for his suit
against the county he is asking for an
additional 75 thousand dollars on top of
his more than quarter million annual
pension it's unjust the taxpayers bear a
large burden for the government
employees pension and these pensions are
much more generous than is available for
them in the course you have to ask is
what's so special about government
employees that they shouldn't have to
assume some of the own risk like the
taxpayer for their retirement as citizen
outrage grew over this disparity the
Ventura County taxpayers association
took action and crafted a pension reform
initiative of which the reason
foundation the nonprofit that publishes
reason TV produced some analysis this
measure does three things it moves all
public employees in the county including
public safety from defined benefit to
defined contribution system it also
freezes pay for five years to keep those
pension costs level and additionally it
guarantees disability and death benefits
for any public safety officials to put
themselves in land duty we've got an
independent actuary and we expect to
save 460 million dollars in cash over 15
years and it will reduce the pension
system liability by one point eight
billion dollars so it's a significant
savings and you know that just creates
opportunities to do you know expanded
services or even you know explore some
new ways to serve the residents of the
county Richard Thompson leads the
Ventura County taxpayers association and
says his group has spent nearly three
years working on the reform initiative
the measure would only apply to new
employees hired after july 2015 under
the plan the county would contribute no
more than four percent of compensation
for general employees and eleven percent
for fire and safety personnel the plan
would also combat the effects of spiking
by placing a cap on the incomes used to
calculate pensions for five years it
will strengthen the promises that were
made to retirees because rather than
this growing pension debt it will it
actually saves money and so those people
that are already retired and those
people that are working today will have
greater confidence in a pension system
that once again isn't paying for itself
the plan was popular with local
residents reformers gathered over 46 of
the needed 21 thousand signatures to put
the measure on the ballot but the
initiative was met with a litany of
resistance from the usual suspects that
oppose reform unions and politicians who
are both bankrolled by the unions and
benefit from rich retirement benefits
public employees turned out in droves to
county board meetings sporting gear
provided to them by local union groups
to voice their opposition some even
showed up at petition drives to
intimidate people from signing union
heads also put pressure on County
Supervisors to delay the reappointment
of Peter Foy the loan supervisor
supporting reform to the Retirement
Board union leaders argue that the
problems of pension debt are being blown
out of proportion they say moving to a
defined contribution plan would put the
public at risk because it would be
difficult to recruit qualified
government workers who often accept
lower pay for better benefits for Sylvia
Ramirez a retiree who's a member of the
local SEIU chapter the proposed pension
plan would bring financial independence
that she thinks people aren't ready for
the 401k is not enough I couldn't afford
it I couldn't afford that money that was
going to take bread and milk away from
my table on that pay day when I was busy
paying my bills but I always knew I had
the security of my pension
people are not as diligent about saving
they're not as understanding they don't
have the knowledge to make the right
choices on which where they want their
monies to go I never could after heated
debate throughout the summer the board
finally agreed to place pension reform
on the ballot but their actions were
made moot after a county judge
preemptively ruled the measure illegal
stating that the existing law under the
1937 act does not permit an individual
county to opt out or terminate its
participation in the pension system
through a countywide vote according to
the judge's ruling even though voters
elected to create a pension fund decades
ago the law provides them no way to exit
the system through a vote reformers
would have to either repeal or amend the
law through state legislation to change
their costly pension programs though the
ruling was a setback the Ventura County
taxpayers association plans to fight for
statewide action and recent Court
rulings that may allow bankrupt cities
like Stockton to restructure their
pension debt could pave another pathway
for reform but before real change can
occur local governments need to
acknowledge the problems in their
retirement systems before their cities
face an inescapable deluge of debt